humor and forgiveness are essential in
this process
have absolute confidence absolute
affirmation and then go for it and if
you're absolutely wrong dead wrong
humor wow I'll bet you there's been
nobody on Earth that's ever been that
wrong I bet you I could get the gold
medal for wrongness and then forgiveness
because forgiveness as we've said before
in previous podcasts is giving yourself
forward
giving yourself back forward so not
being stuck on some bad attitude or some
bad decision that you've made giving
yourself forward to the present moment
and saying okay I'm going to go forward
with just as much confidence and just as
much affirmation and I'm going to go
down this path
dead wrong
humor forgiveness
and you're eventually going to get it
right